this is Startalk Charles white Charles
let me just say thank you for having a
name that I can pronounce okay because
it's my name
Charles white says or asked I have read
articles suggesting the use of caverns
that have been discovered on Mars as
living areas so my question is what if
they get there to find that they aren't
the first ones there ooh
what they have to would they have a
back-up plan or would they be forced to
just go ahead and destroy the indigenous
life and move forward well we certainly
have experience doing that no way right
that there's a playbook already written
on how to bust in to life that already
greets you and you have maybe if you
have higher technology you can take it
over this was like humans have done this
multiple times in the past and it was
never good for the for the you know the
homesteaders no it wasn't yes even in
our movies we do that
avatar yeah yeah the whole idea for
example so so it'd be I'd be curious
what would be living in those caves
because we have very good recon now of
the Martian surface we put spacecraft in
orbit around Mars and here's what's cool
you orbit pole to pole okay and then the
planet rotates inside of that circular
orbit and so every time it coat goes
over it it goes over a new swath of the
planet right and it's kind of like a
diagonal swirl the way year.there swirls
right right well if it's perfect pole to
pole they're just vertical slicers right
but the planets spinning oh the planets
spinning oh yeah so right well let's
just slice it around exactly and this
plant spins once about every 24 hours
which is kind of cool because that's
with the length of Earth Day exactly and
Mars is tipped on its axis and like
Earth and then has seasons like Earth
and ice caps like the earth okay you're
scaring the future earth and it ain't
looking good
so if there's something in the cave it
can't be it's it's not doesn't do much
wandering something wish we would have
seen tracks coming out of these caves
we would have seen garbage tossed out
the back door
banana peels you know whatever they're
eating so sloppy Martians so III don't
know I'd like to think that if there
were some kind of creature there that we
would make peace with it and study it
and and I'd like to think that but I'd I
have low confidence given actual
behavior of actual humans in the past
right yeah yeah we we don't even do that
to us so you know we're not gonna do
that to a mark exactly exactly so there
you go Charles your answer is we are
awful species who will destroy whatever
we find on Mars yeah yeah I know I'm not
wishing that were the case I'm just like
sure ting hey past performance is pretty
much an indicator of future expectations
so all right cool let you don't you do
if you send just scientist you'll just
be really curious what the hell it is
that's the real deal yeah does seem that
they won't want to destroy it for the
sake of preserving and studying and
studying it and and and and maybe they
don't want to be studied but that's
better than being enslaved right exactly
yeah so you send scientists and we'll
find out what it is send Donald Trump
and we'll have a condo out of the cakes
so that's really what it comes down to
developers and scientists have two
different goals right cool
this is Startalk